Senate Republicans are going to try
again a last-resort effort to repeal
Obamacare is in effect but can they
shore up enough support this time a vote
is expected next week on new legislation
put forward by Senators Bill Cassidy and
Lindsey Graham this one still not
getting Rand Paul's seal of approval
this is not repeal this is not what we
promised and the thing is this is not
the last chance we will have many more
opportunities Obamacare is unwinding and
there's nobody for repeal more than I
but I can't provoke for something that's
not really repealed President Trump
calls the bill great and says Rand is a
friend but singles them out as they
quote negative force when it comes to
fixing health care he was here's more
from earlier from the president I think
there's tremendous support for I think
it's actually much better than the
previous shot which was very sadly but
then I think a lot of Republicans are
embarrassed by it but I have to tell you
I think they do a great job if this
happens former President Obama sounded
off today on the new attempt to overhaul
his signature legislation when I see
people trying to undo that hard-won
progress for the 50th or 60th time it is
aggravating and it's certainly
frustrated have to mobilize every couple
of months to keep our leaders from
inflicting real human suffering on our
constituents all right let's begin with
Rand Paul Kimberly how there's anything
you can do besides fully uprooting
Obamacare from the ground to please the
senator from Kentucky I know that's the
thing but you know what he's he holds
his ground on principle respecting he
does so he said look he's being
consistent he said and every time I will
offer an alternative in case somebody
would like to choose that instead
because I feel that this isn't
sufficient so if you like someone who
stands on his principle okay but do you
want like hey a team player in the weeks
ago so now let's see what happens but
today he's saying listen he has no bid
for it so I'm not sure that he's gonna
go for it at all but the president I
think in kind of one of his most
charming ways to call someone how he was
like hmm I'm said nothing's gonna kind
of please him he's been tough on this
but we really should do this this is our
chance so it's sort of like come on you
know that the clock is running out this
is the chance for the GOP to deliver in
a serious way what's been promised to
the American but you can't sit there and
criticize President Obama and Obamacare
and say that you could do it better and
then fail in this measure over and over
again so this is kind of their
last-ditch effort but I think the
expectation levels a little bit low so
perhaps they're gonna exceed it well
what if Obamacare was working
Republicans wouldn't have to repeal and
replace it at all would that he thinks
it I think it is working and so here's
why Republicans have to repeal and
replace is it working on it yes it is
okay more people work you have an
insurance company no more people in fact
the insurance companies are the ones who
have to get subsidies and bumpers and
all working so bad minute ago you said
it was or anything insurance co we're
getting free money no they're not
getting free money because guess what
they're more Americans insured they were
able to in fact give Americans
guaranteed against positions like
pre-existing condition why are they
leaving the exchanges or some are not
all and they are oh actually no in a
third of the counties in the country
actually they are completely right you
know why because there's uncertainty
caused by Republicans including
President Trump
fortunately the system created the
uncertainty and that's a problem and
it's incredibly cool to say that
Obamacare is working because if your
premiums have gone up a hundred and
sixteen percent like they have in parts
of Arizona saying that it's working for
you that's not working
forcing you to pay for insurance that
you don't need that's not working there
are young people in this country young
healthy people in this country who only
want catastrophic insurance they can't
get that under Obama care so they would
rather pull out of the system entirely
and that causes a great destabilization
and pay the penalty and just go on in
short they have to pay a penalty so
that's part of the equation the fact is
that you see more people with insurance
you see consumer protections for people
who have pre-existing conditions you see
Medicaid
expanding you see in fact the growth of
a health care system that is
market-based Kennedy and so you're
saying entitlement that is not growums
that is not a free market that is not a
symptom of a healthy economy what is
that having the federal government prop
up insurance companies to the tune of
billions of dollars and that's exactly
what would happen if Lamar Alexander and
patty Murray kept going down their
bipartisan path in the Senate I'm
actually happy they're not and you know
this is what I will say about Rand Paul
and you point us out Kimberly there are
people who listen to what the president
said when he was on the campaign trail
agree with them or not but he said I'm
going to build this wall that's a man of
principle promising something trying to
deliver that's exactly what Rand Paul is
doing well I mean it's the same idea the
same mechanism that's the same
principled action and therefore I don't
think you can criticize and write a
message I I really don't know why didn't
you vote for the bill two weeks ago then
this is this is what I think and I don't
want to speak for him because that was a
pointed spokesperson of the evening the
skinny repeal bill actually was meant to
be gutted you know it was meant to be
completely hollowed out and it was going
to be a sort of Franken bill that was
not going to resemble itself at all by
the time it got to the house aren't
sincere about this I mean Kimberly said
at the very start is this
nobody was you Jesse is this a bill as
was promised over seven years fifty or
plus votes
that's better than Obamacare well answer
60% of Americans say no let's keep
Obamacare and fix it make it better at
this point
Republicans are intent on some kind of
political victory because they have none
and they say oh let's push this in the
week even though it's not better for the
American well perhaps one of the ways to
make it better is to do what America
does best which is to take it out of
Washington DC and let the state's decide
this is a bill that would just go back
to federal istic principles and one of
the hang-ups is that the Congressional
Budget Office hasn't scored it meaning
they haven't said how much this will
cost well I can't imagine what the guys
at CBO are trying to do how do you know
what 50 different governors
citizens of those states are going to
decide you don't you don't how do you
know how insurance companies to your
point how do you know how they're going
to react how they're going to raise
premiums and how that is going to affect
the market and a number of people in
charge and just so the audience knows I
guess what you do is you keep Obamacare
all the taxes and the regulations but
you just take all the money and send it
to the states and then they can decide
within the state how to deal with
there's a complication as well with that
because five Republican governors of all
so X you know explained and voice their
displeasure with trying to manage they
don't want to take on the burden of
managed your government health care that
they think perhaps might not be you know
run optimally to that every time a new
governor is elected they're gonna tinker
with it again so so what you got here is
you also put a cap on Medicaid spending
because you're you're giving this money
to the states but then you put a cap on
the spending that does away with the
guaranteed have help pay for a share of
the health care cost for low and medium
moderate income Americans that's a big
burden then potentially on the state so
essentially what you have the
Republicans at the moment doing is say
we don't know a form of a better health
care plan their plan the last plane the
so called skinny plan I think as you
said Kenny was intended to implode it
was intended to metamorphosize so now
they're saying so we don't have a better
plan I tell you what we'll shove it down
on the states and let the governors do
okay but what if there's something about
a federal bureaucracy what if there's
something about a centralized system
that makes it very inefficient to get
that the necessary help to people who
need it most and we see that happen all
the time and that's so what if whatever
Murphy said she could if the states were
given the flexibility then Senator
Murkowski said that's something I could
sell to the people of a lot yeah but
she's given in fact what we see is the
people of Alaska will get less money
under this new plan so they will have
less flexibility but they have less
money the government may be that that's
what matters maybe maybe costs go down
decision-making and more flexibility in
terms of where their dollars go perhaps
people are into that yeah and you know
who's not into it Jimmy Kimmel
very upset we know the backstory had a
young son who need a lot of emergency
surgeries and he did a huge monologue
that got a lot of attention and one of
the things he wanted if anybody's in his
position but doesn't have Kimmel money
that that surgeries should be covered he
spoke out about this new repeal bill
effort the other night they're not
taking care of you they're taking care
of the people who give them money like
insurance companies most of the Congress
people who vote on this bill probably
won't even read it and they want us to
do the same thing they want us to treat
it like an iTunes service agreement and
this guy bill Cassidy just lied right to
my face
bill Cassidy was the sponsor from
Louisiana he was on the show he is
responding to mr. Kimmel he is wrong it
will increase coverage and will protect
those or pre-existing conditions
particularly for those states who have
not had the benefits of Medicaid
expansion we help those in those states
and those are millions of Americans you
think Kimmel's being helpful to the
debate I think everybody has a right to
say what they think I do think that
there are times when and I do this too
when you talk to somebody who has had a
personal experience with something you
tend to listen to them because they have
a compelling story it is moving and you
think gosh he's there there's a good
point there but that's not the best way
to make public policy writ large and kmk
Cassidy from Louisiana he is a doctor
himself and he spent years working in
charity hospitals this is not somebody
who is just basically trying to I could
get rich quick kind of doctor so I think
that there there's a lot of momentum
this week well maybe it lasted 48 hours
for this bill mm-hmm now the met
Congress is going home and can they
withstand the pressure from something
like the Jimmy Kimmel appearance last
night the Facebook comments that will go
around to all of the people Obama like
can they withstand that and come back
and vote for it next week but you and
you bring up a really good point that's
charity hospitals and that's something
that we don't talk about because some of
the very best care in this country comes
from places like Shriners and st. Jude's
and you know the various children's
hospitals in LA yeah
and if you talk to people who've done
surgical residency is they will tell you
they work in County hospitals and there
are so many surgeons who do a lot of pro
bono work and those are some of the most
challenging cases where they actually
learn the most any child who goes to the
hospital who has a life-threatening
heart condition who needs surgery it's
not going to be turned away there's some
country called the Hippocratic oath and
you know if you talk to one of my very
best friends is the head of pediatric
cardiothoracic surgery in Arkansas and
what he does and taking those lives and
those tiny hearts into his hands it
takes so much dedication and hard work
and guts and grace and a soul and and
those of the human beings would never
turn away the kind of people but don't
talk Rand Paul's a doctor too and he's
saying no and I'm not only that the
Hospital Association is saying no the
doctor what he's an eye doctor
yes okay no the AMA is saying no I mean
there's all those groups said yes to
Obamacare and then it imploded it this
is like we're in the spiral and you're
not even paying attention this is like
you know conservatives say something to
each other back and forth they say is
that it's more people insured premiums
Kennedy said going up but not at the
rate they were going up when it when the
bill doctors were taking those patients
and in fact for example on some of the
Obamacare plans and I don't use a not my
own personal story but somebody that I
know they are independent business owner
they have to buy on the Obamacare market
they have a pre-existing condition with
that back condition I need MRI there is
not a doctor on the island of Manhattan
who will see him
so they after he has take a day off of
work go to the Bronx it's triple the
money that he used to pay the
deductibles aren't there and they it's
not like it's working perfectly
because even Hillary Clinton said during
the campaign I'm gonna have to try to
figure out how to fix this if I'm
elected I agree that's why I would say
why can't their 'ti
work on this together instead of this
last-minute rush to somehow give a
victor a political victory
when in real life real people Eric over
its Washington DC long